yeah
oh you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
seven managers mental speakers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right yeah
sorry where's let's take our seats
please
[Music]
[Music]
as you know on December 18th the House
of Representatives upheld its
constitutional duty and voted articles
of impeachment against the President of
the United States Donald Trump he said
in the course of the debate that he did
not uphold his oath of office protect
preserve and defend the Constitution of
the United States the president takes a
special OS a little different from the
congressional of Netaji takes an oath
that was taken by President George
Washington the patriarch of our concert
in front of the debate that he did not
uphold his oath of office protect
preserve and defend the Constitution of
the United States the president takes a
special OS a little different from the
Congressional oath Netaji takes an oath
that was taken by President George
Washington to patriarch of our concert
in front of roots to this place so today
we will make history when we walk down
that when the managers walk down the
hall across the threshold in history
delivering articles of impeachment
against the President of the United
States for abuse of power and
obstruction of the house as we make that
history we were making progress for the
American people
progress in support of our Constitution
progress in honor of the sacrifice and
the vision of our founders progress an
honor of the sacrifice of our men and
women in uniform and progress for the
future of our children make it be very
clear that this president will be held
accountable that no one is above the law
and that no future president should ever
entertain the idea that article 1 I mean
she's the article 2
that he can do whatever he wants and so
with that we I will sign the leather
resolution transmitting the articles of
impeachment to the Senate which will be
delivered by our our managers from I'm
very proud when they bring this over
will set in motion a process on the
Senate side probably tomorrow I don't
know their schedule but it may be as
soon as tomorrow
the Senators will take an oath of office
they will take a special ELISA bought us
to do impartial judges and do impartial
justice according to the Constitution
and the laws let's hope that they oppose
that oath that they take tomorrow and so
now I'm very honored that to be here
with their their six chairmen who worked
so hard to help us uphold the
Constitution with their legislating
they're investigating they're litigating
you know they determine of the Judiciary
Committee is part of the managers
hearing now there mister
and so now I'm very honored that to be
here with our our six chairmen who
worked so hard to help us uphold the
Constitution with their legislating
they're investigating they're litigating
you know the chairman of the Judiciary
Committee is part of the managers during
neither mr. Elliot angle of the Foreign
Affairs Committee and Richie Neal
chairman of the Ways and Means Committee
chairman of the Ways and Means Committee
we thank them for all of their difficult
work and we honor our darling Elijah
Cummings who said when one day we were
dancing with the Angels what would we
say about what we did at this difficult
time in our country's history and then
I'm very proud that mr. Nadler and mr.
mr. Schiff are part of our managers but
I
to acknowledge our other managers who
are with us a freshman member but I
shouldn't say freshmen these butts
they've been here one year accomplish
great things
Jase congressman Jason crow of Colorado
way congresswoman Val Demmings a fluke
the state of Florida congresswoman
Garcia of Texas but we all here where we
where's Hakeem Hakeem is a Hakeem I
distinguished chair of our caucus Hakeem
Jeffries of New York said everybody
tries as O'Laughlin this is those third
of impeachment she was a she for the
Nixon impeachment she was a staffer for
a Judiciary Committee member Don Edwards
of California
she was member joshy Airy Committee and
then Clinton impeachment in her own
right a member of the Judiciary
Committee and now members judiciary
chair of House administration with
oversees elections appoints all of this
and a manager so with that I thank them
all for their leadership and their
service and I'm now going to proceed to
sign the articles
possession
she's gonna follow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
heads up the procession is starting
just
a resolution appointing and authorizing
managers for the impeachment trial of
Donald John Trump President of the
United States the message will be
received
mr. president the majority leader I ask
unanimous consent that pursuant to rule
1 of the rules and procedure and
practice when sitting on impeachment
trials the secretary of the senate
informed the House of Representatives
that the Senate is ready to receive the
managers appointed by the house for the
purpose of exhibiting articles of
impeachment against Tom John Trump
President of the United States agreeably
to the notice communicated to the Senate
further that at the hour of 12:00 noon
on Thursday January 16th 2020 the Senate
will receive the managers on the part of
the House of Representatives in order
that they may present an exhibit the
articles of impeachment against Tom John
Trump President of the United States is
there any objection if not sorg ask
unanimous consent that pursuant to rule
3 and 4 of the rules of procedure and
practice when sitting on impeachment
trials that at the hour of 2:00 p.m. on
Thursday January 16
2020 the Senate proceed to the
consideration of the articles of
impeachment and that the presiding
officer through the Secretary of the
Senate notify the Chief Justice of the
United States of the time and place
fixed for consideration of the articles
and requests his attendance as presiding
officer pursuant to article 1 section 3
Clause 6 of the US Constitution is there
any objection so ordered I ask unanimous
consent that the presiding officer be
authorized to appoint a committee of
senators to upon the recommendation of
the majority leader and to upon the
recommendation of the Democratic leader
to escort the Chief Justice into the
Senate chamber I further ask is there
any objection so ordered I ask unanimous
consent that the presiding officer be
authorized to appoint a committee of
senators to upon the recommendation of
the
Oh leader and - upon the recommendation
of the Democratic leader to escort the
Chief Justice into the Senate chamber I
further as the Senate win the Senate
floor and the Senate chamber galleries
during all of the proceedings involving
the exhibition of consideration of the
articles of impeachment against Donald
John Trump President of the United
States and all times that the Senate is
sitting in trial with the Chief Justice
of the United States presiding be in
accordance with the allocations and
provisions are now sent to the desk and
I ask that it be printed in the record
is there objection if not it's ordered I
ask unanimous consent the Senate proceed
to the consideration of s res 471
submitted earlier today the clerk will
report
Senate resolution 471 authorizing the
taking of a photograph in the chamber of
the United States Senate is there
objection to proceeding to the
consideration without objection then the
Senate will proceed ask unanimous
consent the resolution be agreed to and
the motion to reconsider be considered
made and laid upon the table with no
intervening action or debate without
objection so ordered now mr. president
the information of all senators a few
minutes ago the Senate was notified that
the House of Representatives is finally
ready to proceed with their articles of
impeachment
so by unanimous consent we have just
laid some of the groundwork that will
structure the next several days we've
officially invited the house managers to
come to the Senate tomorrow at noon to
exhibit their articles of impeachment
then later tomorrow afternoon at 2:00
p.m. the Chief Justice of the United
States will arrive here in the Senate he
will be sworn in by the President Pro
Tem
senator Grassley then the Chief Justice
will swear on all of us senators will
pledge to rise above the petty
factionalism and do justice for our
institutions for our state's and for the
nation and then we will formally notify
the White House of our pending trial
and summon the President to answer the
articles and send his counsel so the
trial will commence in earnest on
Tuesday but first mr. president some
important good news for the country we
anticipate the Senate will finish the
USMC a tomorrow and send this landmark
trade deal to President Trump for his
signature a major victory for the
administration but more importantly for
American families so let me close with
us this is a difficult time for our
country but this is precisely the kind
of time for which the framers created
this Center I'm confident this body can
rise above short-termism
and factional fever and serve the
long-term best interest of our nation we
can do this and we must
circa call the roll
mr. Alexander
drink
simply helped a lad and file into it
I throw it in there
don't be doing it
we're crossing this court uniform
Oh
[Music]
[Music]